(cheery music)
- Okay, I'm Lois.
- And I'm Charlie.
We have been told, and we
believe, that we have the largest
private collection of
insects in the world.
- [Lois] Yeah.
(Lois laughing)
- The story of how we met
was interesting enough.
I was a teaching assistant
at the University of Arizona,
and Lois was a student in the
class that I was teaching.
We've been married for almost 55 years.
- He's got a million
stories about insects,
all of which I've heard,
and all of which I can
fill in sentences.
- And we've traveled
extensively, have been to all
the continents, and 70
countries, collecting.
It fills us with pleasure to
get into the field and collect,
to spend the time in the field together.
Oh, you need to look at the
antennae on one of these.
It looks like a clown shoe.
Well, I study weevils, and
the weevils are the largest
family of living organisms.
- These are plant hoppers, and
I think their noses are cute.
I collect plant hoppers,
which are insects that feed
on the juices of plants,
the phloem or the xylem.
- With piercing, sucking mouth parts.
- Oh yeah, this is interesting.
- When we get some insects
in, they're just dead.
Of course we have to mount
them, so we have to pin them,
or point them, and then we label them.
Ah, the glue was not stiff
enough and he's falling
off his point.
Then, after I do that,
then I sort them to genus.
- [Charlie] Each of these
units, trays, holds 55 specimens
on average, and we have
at least a million weevils
and a quarter of a million plant hoppers.
- Okay, here you come, darling.
- [Charlie] We are donating the collection
to Arizona State University.
- [Lois] And there will
be research done on it,
which is what we wanted to have happen.
- [Charlie] When we were
entomologists at the university,
we worked 14 hours a
day, seven days a week.
Now we're down to eight
to ten hours a day,
seven days a week.
It's a lot of work, but we
both loved what we were doing
and sharing it was part of our life.
- Now, which one do you
think is the prettiest?
- [Charlie] These two.
- I don't like that one.
- Lois has often taken note of
the fact that a very large
number of entomologists are divorced.
- What I recommend is, if
you're going to be a taxonomist,
a systematist, collect insects.
You get a spouse that
is another entomologist.